annabelle offer real life entertaining
I'm from New York City I think it's
shaped me because it's a city that's
really difficult to live in and finding
solutions and making it work and working
within ideal circumstances is what New
York is all about whether you're the
poorest New Yorker or the richest New
Yorker you're still dealing with problem
solving all day long and it's shaped the
way I view everything I assume I'm not
going to have everything I need to have
to make things happen and I assume that
everything is not going to be perfect in
the end and I somehow come up with a way
of making it feel great and work for me
well I would probably say my uncle was
my greatest influence Steve Rubell heat
when I was seven he opened studio 54 and
he was like a god to me and he was as
much a God because he'd walk into you
know Greek coffee shop and know
everybody there by name and he'd be at
the door of studio 54 and be welcoming
in Halston and Liza Minnelli and farrah
fawcett Ryan O'Neal and have that same
kind of intimacy with them he was just
incredible an incredible connector of
people incredible mixer of people sort
of the opposite of a VIP only culture
that you have now in clubs it was really
about the mixers is passionate about a
17 year old kid who would fish for money
under the bars as some you know exciting
fashion designer or actor well I was at
a constant crisis growing off about what
I would be when I grow when I grew up
because there wasn't really a profession
that fit and I remember saying to my
parents are certain part I must have
been like 10 or 11 I said all I really
want to do is the stuff people do at
home but I want to work I don't want to
be a housewife and I don't know what to
do and they you know of course laughed
at me but I think Martha Stewart had a
really massive impact on the entire
industry of food and writing about food
and thinking about food and producing
different kinds of food because she
really
created a model for making a living
following a passion for food and
entertaining especially in my case